hey youtubers is Charlie so I'm back
from my trip and I wanted to cordially
invite you to the wedding of Joffrey
Baratheon and Margaery Tyrell so for my
bonus video this week I wanted to dive
deep into the purple wedding itself you
know as well let's talk about some of
the running plot threads going on around
it in this giant epic party that they're
throwing in King's Landing basically
like I said my video tonight will be a
regular episode review so be sure to
subscribe to get it if you're finding me
for the first time I do bonus videos for
Game of Thrones every week and I do a
weekly giveaway which will actually
start whenever I post that review
tonight so just to avoid mega spoilers
please be nice in the comments for this
video at least until the episode airs
for people who haven't read the books
but let's get going because there's so
much we have to talk about so like I
said there's the production itself the
actual wedding and the banquet and then
all the side stories happening around it
so I'm going to start with some context
wTF is it called the purple wedding you
know if it was never called that in the
books the real answer is is that it's
called the purple wedding mostly because
of the red wedding last year and because
the show became so popular but there's a
couple other reasons too the color
purple itself was chosen just because of
the color of the MacGuffin you know the
thing that drives the plot for but isn't
necessarily that important I'm not going
to say what that is here but essentially
it's this small thing that just gets
overlooked it ends up becoming much more
important than you think it is and it
just happens to be purple the term the
purple wedding is never used in the
books but because you know the red
wedding episode last year became so
popular colored weddings became a thing
so now we know why it's called the
purple wedding but there's so much more
going on besides the wedding and the
banquet itself it's easy to get started
with all the shininess and the trailers
so as epic as the wedding is it almost
didn't happen remember in season 3 and
it's season 2 they kind of alluded to
the fact that the crown is essentially
bankrupt but like in Super debt to the
Lannisters and the iron bank the
Lannisters owned about half their debt
the iron bank the rest it all goes back
to Littlefinger
remember how he revealed to Catelyn that
he had gone to great gatsby links to
destabilize the crown using all this
debt so that you know chaos would erupt
and they might be able to be together
again freaking crazy I know if you
didn't think he was nuts before all the
Sansa creeping and the brothel scenes
then that chaos is a ladder speech
really kind of sealed the coffin shut
even Varys was a little disgusted in him
and he was keeping someone locked in a
box so for all intents and purposes the
crown or the monarchy depending
how you want to think about it is
totally broke the baratheon might still
have some money but Stannis pretty much
burn it all whenever those ships blew up
in the Battle of Blackwater and even he
was borrowing those on credit we haven't
seen the character yet but Mark Gatiss
is playing someone from the iron bank of
Braavos so I can only imagine what
they're gonna do if they don't get their
money ever since Tywin has been in power
though the crowd has been borrowing
money from the Lannisters and a pretty
stiff interest-rate
you know rich get richer but once
Joffrey took the throne in season 1
they basically forgave all that debt
they still owe millions to the iron bank
though so if the iron bank ends up going
after Stannis then it's pretty likely
that they'll also go after King's
Landing at some point - or it's always
possible that they could just turn
around and fund their enemies which is
really just Daenerys right now that's
actually a pretty interesting way to win
a war you know just cut off their supply
of money and fund their enemies that's
why we saw that scene with Tywin and the
Queen of thorns last season where they
haggled over who would pay for Joffrey
and Margaery wedding you know because
the crown itself could not think about
the war of the five kings this way now
you know anyone who becomes king next
would inherit all that debt so just ask
yourself how badly do you want the Iron
Throne now if you know that you're
entering into that situation now that we
understand this shitstorm of debt in the
iron bank brewing around King's Landing
let's talk about the actual shooting of
the episode itself the actual production
the way the actors actually talk about
the wedding makes it sound like it's the
most baller thing that's happened in
Westeros ever I can't imagine the
Targaryen went too crazy with their
weddings just because they were sister
wives so much so I think that's why in
all the clips we've seen the wedding
itself looks super garish like putting
gold rims on an old car when you don't
have any money to begin with Charles
dance actually said that the wedding in
the banquet themselves felt like its own
little short film inside this episode
because it was so elaborate they ended
up having more extras and people just
physical bodies on set those days than
in any episode since the season 1
premiere I think that episode is still
technically the largest episode in terms
of character seen on screen but if you
look at these behind the scenes pictures
you can almost see every single
character associated with King's Landing
you know every character that has
appeared on screen in a kings landing
scene you know that's a lot of people
that's why one of the things I'm looking
forward to most in the episode is just
seeing how epic everything looks just
physically looks because
Game of Thrones has some of the best
sets in the best costumes just look at
the amount of detail that went into
Jamie's golden hand someone actually
made that custom I love the way they
just kind of casually dismissed it in
the episode of Two as if Cersei just
found it in the dime store in flea
bottom but now let's talk about Sansa
for a second because as all this goes on
she's actually one character that might
have a reason to be happy it's implied
or she thinks it's implied that once
Joffrey marries Margaery his attention
span for torturing her will just fade
away and he'll just start devoting
himself to being horrible to Margaery
during her wedding to Tyrion last year
he did kind of say that he'd never be
completely done tormenting her but if
it's so easy for Tyrion to make him
fraught with the mouth I think that
Margaery would be able to handle him
or at least distract him last week
during the first episode we also got to
see a lot of new scenes with the Queen
of thorns who is a really interesting
character and I think really important
but because she's a female on the show
you know the other characters just kind
of casually dismiss her so I'll be
watching her very closely during this
episode I kind of think of her as like a
female Tywin you know they are pretty
evenly matched and she has been learning
all about Joffrey's true nature so just
because Margaery is willing to jump into
bed with the monster so to speak doesn't
mean that her family isn't taking steps
to protect her so the characters that
I'm planning on watching really closely
in this episode are going to be you know
Joffrey Margaery of course sansan Tyrion
just because they're so interesting and
the Queen of thorns don't forget though
there's also a bunch of bran scenes -
bran is still on his journey to find the
three-eyed Raven beyond the wall so I'm
really interested to see how those
scenes in this episode you know work
against the wedding scenes there's so
many more crazy things that'll happen in
the episode and at the wedding itself so
it's really hard to just pick a few
characters to follow so all that being
said let me know what are you most
looking forward to in the episode you
know the wedding itself which is going
to be totally crazy
the bran scenes or do you think we're
gonna get some surprise Stannis so like
I said my actual episode review will
dive a lot deeper into specific moments
from the episode as well as that purple
MacGuffin I'll explain that a little bit
more and the second random I giveaway
will start all you have to do to
participate is be a subscriber and leave
a comment whenever I post that video you
can actually click here to watch that
right now I'll have the annotations that
post the video and you can click here to
watch all my other Game of Thrones bonus
videos thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight it's gonna be
so
awesome high fives